there's all kind of chaos and
uncertainty across global markets but
bitcoin's price has been grinding up
higher and higher so let's take a look
at what's been going on this past week
first if we look at the bitcoin market
you can see that we're trading around 46
500
that's outperforming most of their
assets over the past week if we then
take a look at the bitcoin network
itself what we can see is that the
bitcoin market cap is just under 900
billion dollars now about 90 of the
supply has been issued and the 19th
million bitcoin has now officially been
put into circulation the real exchange
volume is 1.98 billion dollars and
miners were paid 42.5 million dollars
over the last 24 hours to continue to
secure bitcoin the most secure computing
network in the world bitcoin is also
trading at 40 up from the cycle low but
bitcoin has only ever been 210 days
higher than the current price point so
for over 95 of bitcoin's life it was at
a lower price point this is important
because if you continue to dollar cost
average you're probably in a pretty good
position if we then take a look at the
compound annual growth rate what we can
see is that bitcoin's 10-year compound
annual growth rate is 150 percent that
is destroying anything including the s p
which is only twelve point four percent
or the nasdaq at sixteen point six
percent bitcoin continues to compound at
an incredible pace and it doesn't have
any signs of slowing down anytime soon
now if we take a look at on chain
metrics we'll go to will clemente and
the blockwear team they put together
some great charts this week on it first
we see the short-term holdered realized
price we're just above it but according
to will we're gonna have to see another
day or two of closing above this level
that short term holder realized price
it's important to trade above it we're
there now but let's see if it holds then
if we go ahead and we take a look at the
next chart what we can see is that the
luna bitcoin holdings now as a reminder
luna has the ust which is a stable coin
they're backing it with bitcoin and you
can see here in this green line that
they continue to stack more and more
bitcoin they have three billion dollars
in reserves they're going to convert
into bitcoin with a goal of eventually
reaching 10 billion dollars in bitcoin
any time that you have a persistent
buyer in the billions of dollars coming
into the market of course the price is
going to be positively impacted and what
you can see is pretty much as soon as
they started to buy that price started
to skyrocket upwards if we then take a
look at the bitcoin balance on exchanges
what we can see is this green line
falling off a cliff since early march
that shows that people who had bitcoin
on exchanges who had recently bought it
they actually are moving it now taking
it off that exchange into self-custody
or cold storage that's a great sign for
bitcoin bulls because what it means is
that there's less bitcoin on the
exchange that simply in a couple of
clicks could be sold into the market
less cell pressure on the market
obviously means that the price is likely
to be bullish if we then go ahead and we
take a look at the otc desk holdings as
well we can see that they have fallen
off a cliff as well this is just another
signal showing that there is low cell
pressure meaning that the bulls are in
control the price continues to grind
upwards and every single data point we
have shows that it's likely to continue
and then last but not least if we take a
look at that illiquid supply shock ratio
we can see that that is ticked up
aggressively in the last week that green
line climbing towards the moon what this
tells us is that more and more and more
people are holding bitcoin they're not
willing to sell it over 70 percent of
bitcoin has not been sold in the last
year that's in circulation that's a big
deal because when you have a persistent
buyer like luna or even microstrategy
with their brand new 205 million dollar
loan that they took from silvergate
against their bitcoin collateral that's
hundreds of millions or billions of
dollars pouring into a market that's
highly illiquid that usually spells for
a bullish outlook
then lastly if we shift to the macro
environment we can see dylan leclair
pointing out that officially the 10 and
two year yield curves have officially
inverted once you get this inversion
historically it signals that there is a
recession that is looming now that
recession doesn't usually happen right
away it can take anywhere from six to 18
months to actually go ahead and play out
in some cases it happens on the shorter
end on other cases it happens over a
longer period of time but any time you
get a yield curve inversion you have to
start asking yourself where is the
recession going to come from when is it
going to happen ultimately this yield
curve inversion tells us one thing
people are going to be seeking safety
and regardless of whether wall street
treats bitcoin as a risk asset or not
the everyday average person they treat
bitcoin as their reserve asset they
continue to dollar cost average we have
an illiquid market there's plenty of
persistent buyers the price is grinding
up and even with a recession potentially
looming six to 18 months away
bitcoin looks not only healthy but it
looks like we're poised for a move
higher i hope that you enjoy these
breakdowns every single week next week
i'll be back with will clemente from
blockwear if you don't go follow him on
twitter go follow dylan and we'll be
back next saturday